zum schutz von uns zum schutz unseres
landes
dafür setzen sich die soldatinnen und
soldaten des österreichischen
bundesheeres täglich ein
ein einsatz der angesichts der neuen
bedrohungslage immer wichtiger wird
um unsere bevölkerung auch weiterhin
bestmöglich zu beschützen wird das
unfair jetzt modernisiert und damit
gestärkt durch eine umfassende
bauoffensive beim bundesheer insgesamt
115 millionen euro investiert das
bundesheer 2017 in bauliche maßnahmen
mit folgenden schwerpunkten alte
kasernen werden saniert und damit für
grundwehrdiener attraktiver außerdem
werden neue trainingseinrichtungen und
moderne infrastruktur errichtet für
optimale arbeitsbedingungen altbestand
sanieren um die einsatzbereitschaft zu
erhalten braucht das bundesheer genügend
grundwehrdiener damit der
grundwehrdienst attraktiver wird werden
jetzt 15 kasernen in ganz österreich
generalsaniert wie die us kaserne in
niederösterreich
hier werden sechs company gebäude
komplett erneuert in der stadt schützen
kaserne innsbruck wird ein
unterkunftsgebäude generalsaniert
genauso wie am fliegerhorst
hinterstoisser in zeltweg
[Musik]
und in der vintage kaserne in klagenfurt
wird die stellungs kommission
runderneuert der startschuss für die
sanierung aller stellungs kommissionen
österreichweit neue
trainingseinrichtungen und moderne
infrastruktur damit die soldatinnen und
soldaten des bundesheeres noch besser
für den möglichen ernstfall trainieren
können werden 2017 an mehreren
standorten neue sportanlagen gebaut
[Musik]
außerdem sorgt in zukunft eine moderne
infrastruktur für optimale
arbeitsbedingungen eines der größten
aktuellen bauprojekte die dir aber
kaserne im niederösterreichischen welt
hier entsteht ein neuer werkstätten und
garagen bezirks moderne geräte und
ausrüstung und in der
schwarzenbergkaserne in salzburg gibt es
bald eine neue moderne
zweifachsporthalle einrichtungen die den
dienst für soldatinnen und soldaten
attraktiver machen und ihre
leistungsfähigkeit steigern
außerdem kurbeln diese investitionen die
österreichische bauwirtschaft an und
sichern arbeitsplätze
denn die aufträge werden überwiegend an
heimische betriebe vergeben
das österreichische bundesheer ein heer
von möglichkeiten mit sicherheit
für uns alle